well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages
in the next half hour or so then we'll
see what's making the headlines with the
observer's chief lead writer
sonia soder and the columnist for the
article ali mirage on
a huge night of news it has to be said
let's just see how the papers
uh shall we are reacting to all of
what's happened
and as you'll see developments in the
george floyd and the football super
league stories have been
fast moving let's show you the first
editions that we've received so far
beginning with the telegraph which shows
the celebrations outside the court in
minneapolis
after the guilty verdicts in george
floyd's murder trial though their main
story concerns the incredibly small
number of
hospital admissions for curvid among
people who've been vaccinated
they do mention the super league at the
very top there metro
which we received some time ago has word
of chelsea manchester city's intention
to withdraw from football's new european
super league their headline they think
it's all over
here's the times headline then super
league crumbles as clubs bow to fan fury
defeat of greed is how the daily mail
describes today's developments
the eye calls the story an own goal for
football
the guardian pictures jubilant chelsea
fans outside stamford bridge
after their teams climbed down the sun
also
in an exultant mood proclaiming cheerio
cheerio cheerio
the star mocks the six english clubs who
are lined up to take part declaring
their knees have gone all trembling
while the mirror attempts a pun of sorts
you're not singing
anymore in other news the express hears
that the government plans to send
antibiotic pills to people
self-isolating with covert at home
in the hope of allowing them to recover
more quickly
to global affairs well plenty to discuss
then sonya soda ali mirage are here
and certainly the collapse or the
seeming collapse of the european super
league
and uh this successful conviction of
derek chauvin
had people power behind it didn't it
let's start with the daily mail it
covers both those stories
uh guilty it says first of all for
george floyd
and two on the european super league
story but let's start with
george floyd sonia your reaction we've
seen the scenes in minneapolis what uh
what do you feel about what you've seen
well i think overwhelmingly it's a sense
of
relief at the end of a year of kind of
great sadness
um i think it's a really historic
conviction i think all thoughts have to
be with george floyd's
family and indeed we've been hearing
from um some of his siblings
um just now in that press conference um
i think the reason why it's so historic
is that it's really uncommon for
uh officers on duty to be convicted of
of sort of unlawful killings
and um you know the reason why it
happened
in this case is because a very brave
young black woman captured on footage
the moments
the horrifying horrific moments in which
derek shoving
murdered george floyd and it was because
of that footage i think that it was um
it was much easier for prosecutors to
kind of successfully take a case
against eric shovin so i think going
forward
i mean this is i think it's it is a
really historic moment for america
it's a moment of reckoning um in terms
of
uh racial injustice uh you know we we've
known
derrick george floyd is by far
from the only black person to be killed
by white police officers in the us but
it is unusual because in this case
uh derek chavin has been charged with
his murder but i think it's only the f
you know and today we saw derek chauvin
as an individual being held accountable
for his awful crime
but i think going forwards for the us
this is just
the first step i think in terms of that
reckoning
around racial injustice um that you know
the us has been grappling with for so
long
yes indeed as you say uh members of
george floyd's family have been speaking
we'll
hear from them shortly certainly um but
in the meantime
amanda gorman who spoke so eloquently at
the inauguration of joe biden
uh ali has said a reminder that victory
would be george floyd being alive
every day black americans worry if they
will be next
is another day without justice and
certainly many people
look at the scenes on the front page of
the telegraph the huge jubilation
for many people this is just the first
step isn't it
it is and there's a serious problem uh
with
unscrupulous police officers in the u.s
who abuse their badge to inflict harm
and in this case uh you know murder
someone i mean
it's absolutely um beyond the pale i
mean
you think back to 1992 with the beating
up of rodney king which again was
captured on camera
and when those um officers who did that
were acquitted
there were riots that lasted for days
resulting in the deaths of over 60
people
thankfully that has not happened here
but tensions
clearly were running extremely high on
the streets of minneapolis and only
at the weekend another black american
um was also killed dante wright
so tensions have been running really
really high i mean our thoughts
are with um the family of george floyd
this evening
justice uh seems to have been done here
which is good it's very very big step
forward for america
i do think however that politicians need
to be very careful
in these trials when these trials are
ongoing and live
because they could prejudice the results
i mean we've already had
this case of a of a democrat
congresswoman making statements
um which uh the trial judge himself said
were really deeply unhelpful and we also
had the u.s president also saying that
he was hoping for the right results so
politicians should just be really really
careful in jury trials
of prejudicing them and letting let's
let um
the legal uh yeah except ali in this
case they were sequestered weren't they
so
they wouldn't have heard those comments
of joe biden who said in fact he thought
the case was made overwhelmingly
nancy pelosi's just tweeted too george
floyd should be alive today
similar sentiment his family's calls for
justice for his murder
were heard around the world he did not
die in vain and in fact the police
officers federation of minneapolis has
just also
put out a statement we want to reach out
to the community and still express
our deep remorse for their pain as we
feel it every day as well
there are no winners in this case and we
respect the jury's decision
we need the political pandering to stop
and the race-baiting of elected
officials to stop we need to stop the
divisive comments
and we all need to do better to create a
minneapolis we all
love um obviously this is difficult for
police officers too isn't it
this case sonia but the scenes outside
uh the relief the tears from everybody
does it
does it go some way do you think to
answer the pain
um the pain of people around the world
really who came out
uh you know on on their own feet to
protest at this death
yeah well i think that's why there's a
lot of uh relief there because i think
anyone who saw that i mean it's just so
haunting
um the footage um
of what happened to uh george floyd um
you know you can't watch that footage
and not think that derek shaven should
have been convicted of his murder
but it wasn't guaranteed and so i think
the u.s and indeed much of the world
that's been watching this trial has been
on tenterhooks um waiting to see what
what verdict the jury came back with so
i think there is a lot of relief that
the jury has reached the right verdict
but i think um you know it's it's just
relief and it's just a first step in the
sense that yes justice has been
meted out in this case but it's only one
case
and when you look at the um justice
system in the us
i mean the rates of incarceration of
black people of black young men
are just staggering the rates of
violence that black young men face at
the hands of white police officers
um the chances of um you know getting
incarcerated for minor drugs offenses
are just so much higher if you're black
in the u.s so
this can only be a first step to
addressing so you know
it's not just one police officer it's
not just
one bad apple i mean obviously derek
chauvin is a man
who committed a heinous crime but he's
part of a system an institutionally
racist police force in the u.s
and there's a lot lot more to be done to
get to justice
for people of color in the united states